elles ont roulé plus de 20 heures pour
atteindre leur objectif la ville de
berre est ovale ouest de l'ukraine l'une
des dernières villes encore épargné par
les bombardements russes ces deux
tourangelle une mère et sa fille vont
tenter de mettre un maximum de réfugiés
à l'abri de l'autre côté de la frontière
hélène chapelet a pu recueillir leurs
témoignages
bon ben voilà
elles ont franchi la frontière
ukrainienne dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi isabelle et sa fille elise sont
partis deux tours samedi matin leur
objectif acheminés aux populations
locales tous les dons qu'elles ont
récolté vêtements produits d'hygiène
nourriture et médicaments
leur périple s'est arrêté à berre et or
au sud ouest de l'ukraine près de la
frontière avec la hongrie sur place pas
de troupes russes la vie suit son cours
même si la population se prépare
[Musique]
normalement avec des magasins les gens
qui font les courses qui vont au café
est en fait il hier
georges de la fin ma thèse
dit que l'apple les magasins se vident
donc par exemple hier il y avait des
yeux bat aujourd'hui un atout
et peu à peu les choses arrivent les
gens ne s'en rendent pas bien compte
encore je pense en tout cas il n'y a pas
du tout cette heure
[Musique]
cette ambiance-là jeu
deux sièges
ça va arriver
une école de la ville a été
réquisitionné pour servir de centre
d'accueil pour les réfugiés c'est là que
les dons sont stockées et que l'on
retrouve nos tourangelle en contact avec
l'association touraine ukraine pendant
une semaine au moins elles vont
désormais tenter de conduire jusqu'à la
frontière les personnes qui souhaitent
quitter le pays
c'est qu'on va pas changer le monde en
venant à 2 ici avec notre voiture en
quête de dons certes mais voilà enfin ça
c'est ce qu' une petite action mais en
tout cas c'est très important pour nous
de le faire et d'apporter toute
l'énergie qu'on pouvait mettre de notre
côté alors ce que je voulais ajouter
aussi c'est que nous on a pu le faire on
a pu venir ici mais ce qu'on ait enfin
c'est vrai que ce que j'avais en tête me
disant voilà nous on peut le faire et
vous aussi vous pouvez faire quelque
chose à vote à votre échelle tout ne
peut pas donner un congé qui venir et
puis lâchez tout mais effectivement
faire des dons que ça soit en argent ou
en matériel c'est déjà vraiment super
important une cagnotte a été créé pour
soutenir ces deux tourangelle et leurs
actions direction le site cotisent à
point comme slash tour ukraine